hello everybody it's June 2019
so this is another monthly update video
in which I'll talk about what we've got
coming up this month and what you might
have missed in the month of May that
just finished up very busy month for me
by the way I always like to begin by
highlighting three big things so with no
further ado big thing number one I've
got a new video premiere later this
month I'm continuing that series on
advice for people carrying out
self-directed study this time I'll be
talking about stoic philosophy so that's
big thing number one big thing number
two I'm gonna try something a little bit
different in my study with sadler
teachable Academy I'm going to create
what they call an email class where you
can sign up and get emails day to day
with a little bit of philosophical
content some things that I've been
developed in the past maybe you'll find
it interesting you can find the link to
that down below for the teachable
Academy and you'll see you know
announcements about that in social media
when it comes out third big thing
happening right here in Milwaukee later
on this month I will be giving a paper
at the Aristotle and the Aristotelian
tradition conference at Marquette
University so if you're in the area and
you want to see me talk about something
that that I've given a lot of thought to
through most that is the spirited or
irascible element within us I'm going to
be there and you can find the link for
that below in the video description as
well alright so let's talk about May it
was a busy month as we geared up for my
kids coming here for the summer and
classes were coming to an end I also had
a few events the philosophers of the
midst of history we had our session
number 14 Believe It or Not for a
quarterly series on Thomas Aquinas the
mendicant orders and the high middle
ages that was a lot of fun it's a video
link to that below we also continued our
worlds of speculative fiction with a
really great series by Tana
the Li and I'm smiling a little bit
because I'm thinking about some of the
crazy reactions to it so Tanith Li wrote
this series called the Flat Earth series
and she wrote it back when you know I
think people had realized that that the
Flat Earth theories were more or less
debunked and she wasn't writing it for a
time like ours in which somehow their
hunt to come back so there were quite a
few thumbs down on the video I think
from people just seeing the title not
realizing that it's actually a fantasy
series set in a flat earth and it has
nothing to do with the flat earthers out
there and then some people chimed in on
it with comments you know trying to make
sure that I knew that the earth wasn't
flat so you know clearly people need to
pay more attention to what video is
going on and read video descriptions
what else did we have you know usual AMA
or ask me anything session we had our
Hegel sessions philosophy chance for
patreon supporters into the philosophy
pop up on YouTube about my
existentialism class that's going on
what else
classes finished up Marquette you know
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
and even MATC all finished up in May
they kind of staggered so I actually
began my first summer class with
Milwaukee Institute of Art Design an
online six-week existentialism class
that I'm currently teaching before my
Milwaukee Area Technical College class
intro to philosophy finished up so it
you know it's kind of a weird
topsy-turvy time a lot of teaching going
on and I've been gearing up for for even
more over this summer what else videos
I've been shooting a lot of core concept
videos on existentialist thinkers and
texts that I use for my online class so
you've probably seen some of the Rainer
Maria Rilke letters to a young poet
videos coming out the Fyodor Dostoevsky
but it notes from the underground some
stuff on Nietzsche's thus Spoke
Zarathustra coming out recently and of
course more content
jean-paul Sartre existentialism is a
humanism and we did you know videos for
the events as well the Thomas Aquinas
the Tanith leeteuk the AMA session I got
a little bit of podcasting done but not
as much as I would have liked it didn't
manage to get Hegel videos done
unfortunately this month so that's
another month without without getting
those I've been kind of stuck in the
spirit section for a while but I did get
some writing done some of it in her exes
do you know idk my main blog of
continuing of course editing stoicism
today which is which is a good bit of
work and I've been doing some academic
writing I reviewed a paper for a journal
and I've been working on my paper for
the Aristotle conference coming up it's
not quite where I want it to be yet but
you know we'll see what happens I've got
you know another 20 days or so de it's
really whip it up into shape so that's
what what went on during the month of
May so we've got a lot of cool stuff
coming up this month of June that we're
already a little bit into coming up this
Saturday that's June 8th at 12 p.m.
Central Time all times are going to be
central so make sure you check your
timezone we'll start with the AMA that's
ask me anything session and I've decided
this time I'm gonna give priority to
questions that haven't been asking
questions about Nick land or Jordan
Peterson or G Jack I'm probably gonna
skip over those this time I'll announce
that at the start I'm looking for more
questions about things that people
haven't asked me in the past or that I
think are more interesting that same day
at 2:00 p.m. we'll be having our patreon
exclusive half hour Haegele session
that's a perk for my patreon supporters
of the project on the 11th that's a
Tuesday at 5 p.m. we'll have our public
half-hour Haegele Q&A and discussion
session that's open to anybody who wants
to come online event you want to ask me
about Hegel you want to talk about
dualism you wanna talk about philosophy
you go right on ahead on the 13th here
locally at the Brookfield Public Library
that's a Thursday night 7:00 p.m. we
will be having our next session in the
worlds of speculative fiction series
that is on piers Anthony's xanthe novels
we're going to talk about the first five
of the 30-plus novels that he wrote and
and so that should be a fun time then on
the 22nd which is a Saturday at 12 p.m.
we'll be having the video premiere for
the the next that is the third entry in
the advice about self-directed study
this time about stoicism it's a video
premiere you if you want to get in on it
you'll be the first people watching it
I'll be there in real time answering
questions responding to comments that
that sort of thing it's a lot of fun
also on the 22nd at 3:00 p.m. we will
have our patreon exclusive philosophy
chat that's video conferencing with me
directly that's a perk for some of my
supporters of my main patreon and then
finally we finish up the month on the
27th at 6 p.m. at the Shorewood Public
Library with our stoic fellowship
meeting that's a local meeting here of
people interested in stoicism we're
going to be talking about Marcus
Aurelius meditations book three and
talking about our attempt to apply the
sort of practice that he outlines at the
very beginning of book two and what
effects it had and and whether it worked
for us or whether it didn't work for us
so that's all the events coming up
I mentioned that I'll have a email class
coming out later this month you want to
look at my social media obviously that's
my Facebook Twitter and LinkedIn those
are the main social media maybe I'll put
an announcement in a video as well
that's that's an idea for a class
that'll you know sort of trickle out
each day you get an email about the
topic I haven't decided yet exactly what
you know I'm
to have the class center on I might do
an intro to philosophy I might do an
introduced introduction of stoicism I
might do something about anger I might
do something about philosophical
traditions we'll we'll see right but
that's coming up and that'll be
available for the general public I'm in
the middle of teaching a six-week online
existentialism class with my Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design students and
next week actually not quite a week away
I start another class with Milwaukee
Area Technical College a seven week
online introduction to ethics class so
I'm developing a lot of new content for
that because in all of my classes are
mostly my content I'm also still
building out the business ethics class
for Marquette University which starts in
July really popular class I've had
students emailing me asking to get in I
don't let them in classes are capped and
that's that and then I'm also working on
a few other initiatives that have to do
with fall classes as well in addition to
that I've you know I got a full load of
client meetings and some consulting work
and things like that and I'm doing my
bit for stoicism today I recently wrote
a piece in stoicism today that we're
gonna have a follow up to this coming
month video work I'm doing a lot of
filming some of it for these classes but
I'm going to also get in some other
stuff as well so you can look forward
this month to seeing core concept videos
Nietzsche's thus Spoke Zarathustra
coming out more core concepts on
Gabrielle Marcel and the ontological
mystery and depending on what the
schedules like you might see the Camus
myth of Sisyphus ones coming out or
those might be in July I'm hoping to get
to shooting my half-hour Hegel videos
again in part because I don't want to be
bogged down in this section the last
portion of spirit morality forever
there's the self-directed study video of
course that'll be coming out look to
Facebook for for the premiere stuff
because I
we post my events in facebook I'm hoping
to get some book review videos done this
month as well and I'm gonna be doing a
lot of other shooting video for the
online classes that may not appear right
away but we'll be going into other
online classes that I'm developing and
the teachable Academy which you can sign
up for once I open them up to the
general public doing a good bit of
writing this month as well I mentioned
that there's the Aristotle Conference so
my paper for that conference is on two
MOS or you know this spirited irascible
passionate element within us in the
Platonic and Aristotelian traditions but
I'll also be talking about the stoic
tradition as well and some other
thinkers who kind of straddle the
boundaries between the halls like Cicero
or Galen
so there's gonna be a lot of interesting
stuff I might film it I might not we'll
see what happens it really depends on
the conference organizers and what the
logistics look like some of these old
school scholars don't really like seeing
video cameras in the room they get a
little nervous about that doing some
other writing as well some I mentioned
stoicism today I'll be doing some
writing in rexis do you know what a TK
hopefully in heavy-metal philosopher oh
I should mention too we got to go see
Judas Priest in Uriah Heep last month
and that was a big highlight as well and
we're gonna see Tiger Knight at pride
just this coming week that's a band that
my my kids really love and there are a
lot of fun to sort of a glam punk metal
band from the local area what else
podcasting so my my child
Matt ak8 OSHA is going to be helping me
out with that we'll see how many podcast
episodes get done but it'll be a hell of
a lot more than what I'm able to do
myself so I think you can look forward
to that that's really great
because then I can also use those in
classes too and then the rest of the
time you know you know I've already got
this pack
the rest of the time I'm spending with
my my kids I'm probably not going to
take on any new client work this month
I'll push it off to next month because I
want to be able to spend some time here
in Milwaukee we've got lots of great
music festivals and hiking and you know
going to the museums and you know
getting to hang out and just teaching
them how to how to cook good dishes and
stuff like that so that's what what's
lined up for me this month I hope that
you have a great first month of summer
and hopefully I'll see some of you
either face-to-face in the events here
in the Milwaukee area or in some of the
online events
you